que s'est il passé
voici une autre version du bernois c'est
là ses débuts en touriste il use amis du
groupe des six
[Musique]
[ __ ] risette 12 g comme plus le goût
d'être agressif lorsqu'il a fondé de 6 m
il y a huit ans avec son frère aîné
hubert le noir était adolescent est
moins populaire
le groupe a enregistré un deuxième album
il ya 18 mois mais la sortie a été
repoussée jusqu'à aujourd'hui à cause du
times mais à cause du bar j'ai vécu son
succès et puis ça le bout ce qui est un
beau leader mais la manne n'est aussi on
l'avait l'album on le trouvait bon
qu'ils sont en dessous d'un inconnu un
master au final c'est profitable pour
tout le monde
[Musique]
ce disque dont la majorité des chansons
sont en anglais a été enregistré à l'été
2010 est et en jour en oregon avec un
des musiciens des black keys
ce deuxième album de décision et celui
du passage à l'âge adulte ce projet la
musique est off ted lavie s'étoffe
leçons du nouvel album de décision et
rock'n roll
inspiré par les années 60 70
est-ce que ça
le fait de parler de façon plus crue
puis de dire la vérité souvent c'est
incroyable à quel point ça ça rassemble
les gens mais que réserve l'avenir à ce
groupe dont l'un des piliers obtient un
succès en solo après comment ça va
tourner je ne sais pas c'est sûr que
c'est inquiétant pour nous un peu parce
que parce que si tu as un c'est un set
up qui vraiment différent de ce qu'on
sera dans son album
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de concerts
prévus pour de six ends ici julie jasmin
boudreau radio canada montréal
allez